customer pilots directed almost 3,000
precision strikes last year we're super
proud of it it allows you to separate
the bad guys from the good it's a big
deal but we have something much bigger
your kids probably have one of these
right not quite
hell of a pilot no that skill is all AI
it's flying itself its processor can
react a hundred times faster than a
human the stochastic motion is an anti
sniper feature just like any mobile
device these days it has cameras and
sensors and just like your phones and
social media apps it does facial
recognition inside here is three grams
of shaped explosive this is how it works
[Music]
did you see that that little bag is
enough to penetrate the skull and
destroy the contents they used to say
guns don't kill people people do well
people don't they get emotional disobey
orders aim high
let's watch the weapons make the
decisions now trust me these were all
bad guys now that is an airstrike of
surgical precision it's one of a range
of products trained as a team they can
penetrate buildings cars trains evade
people bullets pretty much any
countermeasure they cannot be stopped
now I said this was big why because we
are thinking big watch
a 25 million-dollar order now buys this
enough to kill half a city the bad half
nuclear is obsolete take out your entire
enemy virtually risk-free just
characterize him release the swarm and
rest easy these are available today we
have a distribution network taking
orders from military law enforcement and
specialists clients donation is still
recovering from yesterday's incident
which officials are describing as some
kind of automated attack which killed 11
US senators at the Capitol building just
one side of the aisle you can see high
windows very small precisely puncture to
gain entry to the buildings what did you
do to victory I just did what I could
for him
things weren't even interested in me
they just buzzing government sources
admit the intelligence community has no
idea who perpetrated the attack nor
whether it was a state group or even a
single individual so if we can't defend
ourselves then we strike back we are
investing very heavily in classified
defense projects we make it our
deterrent like our nuclear deterrent we
stockpile in the millions the billions
at key facilities the White House the
New York Stock Exchange Wall Street okay
hey aren't we doing a video call today
I'm kinda with people so come on Oliver
put her on oh no it's it's not like that
listen I see some photos here with
somebody
what what is this video right here no
I'm not going to click on our it's just
this human rights thing on earth
oppression honey honey you're not going
into politics are you hey theater just
like you said it would be police are not
saying this morning what prompted the
alert claim relaxing firearm legislation
would be useless against the so-called
slaughter BOTS
as to stay away from crowds when indoors
keep windows covered with shot to
protect your family stay inside
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
authorities are still struggling to make
sense of an attack on university
campuses worldwide which targeted some
students and not others the search for a
motive is apparently turning to social
media and a video shared by the victims
exposing corruption at the hypes
so it's often surprising the weapons
took away the expense danger and risk of
waging war and now we can't afford to
challenge anyone really it's it's not
even not even smallest fringe group or a
crank who could have done this and
anyone dumb weapons drop where you point
them smart weapons consume data when you
can find your enemy using data even by a
hashtag you can target an evil ideology
right where it starts
[Applause]
this short film is more than just
speculation it shows the results of
integrating and miniaturizing
technologies that we already have I'm
Stuart Russell a professor of computer
science at Berkeley I've worked in AI
for more than 35 years it's potential to
benefit humanity's enormous even in
defense allowing machines to choose to
kill humans will be devastating to our
security and freedom thousands of my
fellow researchers agree we have an
opportunity to prevent the future you
just saw but the window to act is
closing fast